so what we have plotted here is some
function let's call it f of x and its
derivative f prime of x what we need to
figure out is which one is f of x
and which one is f prime of x
so let's take a stab at it let's say
let's think about what would be the
situation
if the green function were f of x so
let's see if this works out if the green
function were f x
does the orange function here the yellow
function does that could that be f prime
of x so let's think about what's
happening to this green function at
different points
so this green function right over here
right at this point if we start at the
left has a positive
has a positive slope
while
so if this orange function were f of x
it would need to be positive or sorry if
this orange function were f prime of x
if it were the derivative of the green
function then it would have to be
positive because the green function
slope is positive at that point but we
see that it's not positive so it's
pretty clear that the green function
cannot be f of x and the yellow function
cannot be its derivative because if this
was its derivative it would be positive
here so that quickly we found out we
found out that that can't be the case
but let's see if it could work out the
other way so it's starting to feel just
kind of ruling that situation out that
may be that this is f of x
and the green function is f prime of x
is f prime of x so let's see if this
holds up to scrutiny
so what we have when we start off at the
left
f of x what we think is f of x has a
reasonably positive slope is that
consistent well yeah sure our green
function is positive our green function
is positive in fact at the point is
telling us that the slope of the tangent
line is around two and a half and it
actually does look like the slope of the
tangent line
is exactly two and a half of this
function right here actually let me
erase this just so we don't look like
we're trying to take the slope of the
tangent line of the derivative so let's
just like that so we see the slope of
the tangent line right over here looks
like about two and a half and the value
of this function up here looks like it's
about two and a half so so far this
green function looks like a pretty good
candidate for the derivative for the
derivative of this yellow function but
let's let's keep going here
so let's think about what happens as we
move to the right so here let's see it
looks like the slope
the slope of this yellow function i'm
just in a color we can see
it is it keeps going up
it keeps going up
keeps going up and then at some point it
reaches some maximum slope and then it
starts to go down again it starts to go
down again the slope starts to go down
again
all the way to the slope going all the
way down to zero right over here well
does this green function describe that
well see the slope is positive and
increasing up to this point which seemed
pretty consistent with what we just
experienced then the slope stays
positive but it's positive and
decreasing and that's what we saw here
the slope is positive and decreasing all
the way to the slope getting zero at
this maximum point here and we see
indeed that on this green function the
green function hits zero so it seems
like it's doing a pretty good job of
plotting the slope of the tangent line
of the orange function and then our
slope becomes more and more negative our
slope becomes more and more negative and
then it hits some point some minimum
point right over here the slope hits
some minimum point right over here and
then it becomes less and less negative
and then the slope becomes less see how
well i can draw it the slope becomes
less and less negative until it hits a
zero slope again a zero slope again and
then it starts becoming positive
starts becoming positive until it hits
some maximum slope but it stays positive
but it becomes less positive it becomes
less and less positive so it looks
pretty clear that the orange function is
f x and the green function is f prime of
x